puis au sénégal de nouvelles lois
adoptées pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
inquiète les ong human right watch
alerte les discours politiques et les
manifestations pacifiques pourraient
être assimilées à des actes terroristes
plus de précision avec notre envoyé
spécial à dakar l'île a famous ou des
lois dangereuses aux contours vagues qui
pourraient être utilisés pour
criminaliser les activités politiques
pacifiques
c'est ce que dénonce de nombreuses
organisations humanitaires crise
inquiète de deux projets de loi
approuvés par l'assemblée nationale
sénégalaise c'est loi qui modifie le
code pénal définissent les actes
terroristes comme incluant entre autres
des actes susceptibles de troubler
gravement l'ordre public l'association
de malfaiteurs et les infractions liées
aux technologies de l'information et de
à la communication elles rendent les
dirigeants d'associations de syndicats
ou de partis politiques pénalement
responsable des délits commis par leurs
organisations menaçons en cible le droit
d'association fin juin des membres du
parti de l'opposition ont déposé un
recours auprès du conseil
constitutionnel pour déterminer la
conformité de ces lois à la constitution
sénégalaise et nos obligations
juridiques national mais aussi
international
il faut dire que c'est une belle loi
interviennent dans un climat de tension
politique et d'incertitude accrue au
sénégal la répression de manifestations
pacifiques de grande ampleur en mars a
fait 10 morts et des centaines de
blessés
de nombreux activistes de la société
civile des organisations de la santé
d'autres groupes au sénégal craignent
que ces nouvelles lois antiterroristes
n'est un impact sérieux sur les libertés
civiles et servent à restreindre
davantage encore l espace démocratique
dans le pays